ce n'est pas d'hier que les infirmières
se plaignent d'être surchargé au milieu
des années 90 le gouvernement bouchard
met en place le virage ambulatoire
ce que nous annonçons aujourd'hui c'est
un coup de barre déterminant des
hôpitaux ferment leurs portes
les autres doivent composer avec des
départs de personnels massif sur 390
personnes
nous avons 80 scientifiques des milliers
d'infirmières cannes leur retraite en
l'espace de quelques mois
l'effectif au québec passe de 64 mille
infirmières en 1995 à 59 milles en 1998
un peu je répare que lyon passera dé
nous les infirmières qui reste en place
disent être surchargé en 1999 elles
entreprennent une grève illégale ou
d'une autre les infirmières dénoncent
leurs conditions de travail et réclament
de meilleurs salaires
nous préférons être debout jusqu'au bout
le gouvernement de ce report dans les
années 2000 la pénurie de personnel
infirmier demeure vive depuis le virage
ambulatoire
on a le roulement ou au niveau des
patients qui reste sa durée de séjour et
plus contre ce qui veut dire que les
patients sont beaucoup plus malades
le gouvernement tente par tous les
moyens d'accroître les effectifs hausse
des admissions dans les programmes de
soins infirmiers primes de rétention
pour les infirmières déjà à l'emploi
on parle d'une prime de taux de 100 $
par semaine les conditions de travail
sont difficiles
plusieurs se tourner vers la pratique en
agences privées
une vaste étude démontre que les
infirmières sont épuisés je vois autour
de moi qui a beaucoup de bernad
coup de fatigue beaucoup d'arrêts de
travail au cours des dernières années le
nombre d'infirmières qui exerce la
profession a légèrement progressé pour
se stabiliser autour de 70 milles mais
disent leur syndicat leur tâche c'est
aussi alourdi par exemple selon le
commissaire à la santé et au bien-être
le nombre de patients admis en 6 h et
celle des qui présentent des problèmes
complexes ont crû de 5 % en seulement
trois ans ici go la vallée radio canada
montréal